[Música]
no momento de muita incerteza e de
ansiedade sobre o futuro
em 2005 no auge dos meus 19 anos
eu criei pra mim uma visão para 2025 é
definir os meus valores em palavras e eu
fui seguindo essa direção
a partir dali cada oportunidade decisão
escolha que eu fazia eram feitas de
acordo com se aquilo contribuir ou não
para aquela visão de futuro que incluía
conhecer gente do mundo inteiro e tem
uma influência internacional na criação
de um mundo mais justo e mais inclusivo
para todos os seres vivos que ser parte
da diplomacia que se parte da onu que se
ativista política acadêmica
empreendedora social e fui e vou
transformando essa visão
de acordo com a realidade que eu
encontro no meu dia a dia e que o
construiu
depois de sete anos trabalhando no
terceiro setor
eu encontrei um sócio e o que me fez
sentir preparada pra empreender ea gente
cofundou a emc ainda é pioneira em
disseminar uma certificação
internacional em gestão de projetos
sociais no brasil pmb pro ea gente
acabou sendo os primeiros do mundo a
fazer um curso é aberto do pgm de uma
certificação internacional também gestão
de programas sociais
logo no primeiro ano de trabalho eu fui
convidada para dar uma palestra em goste
então já estava me sentindo o grupo de
criadores dessa metodologia para contar
do sucesso que a gente estava tendo aqui
no brasil
disseminando essa metodologia para as
organizações de base
aquelas que mais precisam na minha visão
o da audiência era formada por pessoas
que trabalhavam em 11 internacionais
e fazia um trabalho super importantes ao
redor do mundo inteiro que eu só sonhava
em poder contribuir sei lá em 2000 e
2010 a 2012
respirei fundo
lembrei que eles tinham me convidado
acreditei que tinha algo para contribuir
e fui
chegou a hora da palestra e quem me
convidou
pegou o microfone para me apresentar e
falou eu estou muito feliz de convidar
ao palco lisiane que é uma prova de que
existe inteligência no sul do mundo
eu nem senti o trem do metrô pelo todo
mundo ali trabalhava diariamente com
pessoas do assim chamado sul do mundo e
não é possível que fosse apresentada
assim só que eu fui
ninguém reagiu era pra ser isso eu
queria fazer isso bem dei o meu melhor
naquela palestra e engoliu sapo fiquei
com um nó para mim eu voltei para o
brasil e continuar trabalhando para
tornar a vida de centenas milhares de
provas vivas de talento e inteligência
que eu via todos os dias foi nessa vida
um pouco mais fáceis
todos os dias eu via eu vejo
empreendedores sociais fazendo
transformações incríveis através de ongs
institutos fundações coletivos projetos
negócios sociais e eu tenho a honra eo
privilégio de servir essas pessoas a em
que aos poucos foi ganhando tração
eu fui encontrando apoio e ganhando
confiança
no mesmo dia e quase no mesmo horário
que eu fui renovar o primeiro contrato
grande da emc que era bem grande pra
aquele momento hoje né
eu tinha uma outra reunião que era muito
importante e uma pessoa com uma posição
de liderança super de uma instituição
o importante é tinha convidado um grupo
de empreendedores para conversar sobre
um projeto novo ea gente estava super
empolgado como eu tinha um sócio a gente
se dividiu
eu fui assinar a renovação ele foi na
reunião do projeto novo assinado
contrato
eu cheguei feliz motivado empolgada para
acompanhar o finalzinho daquela reunião
eu fui incluída com resumo do que tinha
acontecido até ali ea gente conversou
juntos sobre os próximos passos
rapidamente todo mundo muito empolgado e
no final alguém deu a idéia a gente
precisa registrar esse momento histórico
sim precisávamos o poderoso maior que
tinha convidado a gente pois a mão no
seu bolso
tirou seu celular apontou pra mim e
falou você pode tirar foto
eu não lembro que eu senti
eu vi aqueles cinco homens que me
conheciam se posicionarem se abraçarem
como velhos amigos olhamos olhando pra
mim esperando aquele clique
eu tirei aquela foto a gente foi embora
e e como na situação de antes
a ficha aos poucos foi caindo eu fui
percebendo como que a culpa a solidão a
pressão que eu sentia que às vezes eu
mesma chamava de mim ou de exagero eram
reais
mas eu aprendi com essa situação que
quando o preconceito é estrutural
é muito difícil ele ser visto pelo por
quem tem o privilégio de não sofrer ele
a conversa de explicação do que tinha
acontecido naquela situação que eu
precisei ter com o meu sócio foi longa e
um pouco dolorida mas ela valeu muito a
pena
depois de alguns anos de processamento
daquela experiência um pouco de terapia
um pouco de conversa com mulheres
empreendedoras
eu consegui conversar com 325
pessoalmente um a um e todos eles
compreenderam se comprometeram a
serwa e de fato se tornaram aliados
eles estão incluindo e transformando e
realizando muito mais que eles faziam
antes hoje os outros dois
talvez fiquem sabendo só depois de hoje
se esbarrarem na cidade x é e talvez
eles nem se lembrem que eles fizeram
parte desse momento eu tive força para
seguir em frente porque ao mesmo tempo
que eu me encontrava com esses desafios
encontrava muito apoio eu encontrava
parceria cumplicidade clientes
colaboradores e empreendedoras
empreendedores passando por todos os
tipos de desafio se jogando nas
transformações que iriam realizar com
coragem e com determinação e também se
estropiando nas suas falhas próprias que
eu também cometi muitas já falei no
aquino no seu nome e por barreiras
colocadas por situações como a que eu
coloquei e burocracia falta de recursos
todos os desafios que não faltam para
quem se coloca ali na linha de frente
quando eu olho para as experiências de
discriminação que eu relatei aqui eu
vejo sim que eu superei e desenvolve
resiliência
mas eu não posso deixar de pensar em
quem desistiu com razão e nem com mais
longe a gente poderia estar se a gente
fosse aliados nesse caminho às vezes e
aliado significa perceber quem está
faltando uma foto
às vezes é criar um negócio social que
traz ferramentas e recursos novos para
mais empreendedores sociais às vezes
retirar os animais do seu prato
às vezes é que há tempo pra ouvir alguém
que precisa ser ouvido
especialmente ouvir vozes diferentes da
sua
que tentar realmente entender de onde
elas vêm
ciências elas vivem enfim buscar
compartilhar o peso de ser alvo de um
viés ou de uma dívida histórica que a
gente compartilha enquanto humanidade
se você não sabe por onde começar como
eu já não sou eu um dia eu sugiro que se
observe e trabalho para silenciar uma
voz interna que ainda vai ter mais
repetir que você mesmo ou outro ser
não pode ser feliz ou fazer algo que
sonha por causa do seu gênero da cor de
pele da identidade sexual religião
recurso habilidade lugar de nascimento
histórico espécie o que for ao invés
disso tenta criar uma visão de futuro
desejável e começa a trabalhar pra ver
como você pode contribuir para ela
acontecer o que está ao seu alcance
hoje aqui neste palco eu me sinto
bastante realizada e eu sei que ainda
tem muito trabalho para ser feito é para
criar o tal mundo mais justo e inclusivo
para todos os seres vivos que ainda faz
parte do meu sonho
a inquietude a vontade de transformação
seguem em mim
três anos atrás eu comecei um processo
de transição na inc que me trouxe uma
nova sócia carla e um ano atrás com o
apoio da fundação lemann e tive a
possibilidade de embarcar para uma
estrada e empreendedorismo social na
universidade do sul da califórnia
eu estou lá até dezembro pelo menos lá
eu estou aprendendo e ensinando criando
trocando enquanto me do tempo para
redefinir essa visão 2025
ela já parecia perto demais para me
motivar e eu tomando meu tempo pra
ganhar perspectiva e deixar uma nova
visão emergente
eu continuo ouvindo direta ou
indiretamente que eu sou um grande
grande demais e sei que isso vai
continuar acontecendo porque eu vou
continuar usando sonhar do tamanho que a
minha perspectiva alcançar
eu sei que eu compartilho ressoa com
muita gente que passou pelos mesmos por
calças
eu também sei que outros têm
dificuldades muito maiores e encontram
muito menos apoio
por mais que eu tivesse a minha visão
como guia a realização é uma coisa muito
mais incerta
quando você está vendo de primeira mão
quando você está tendo que abrir esse
caminho seja por vontade por escolha ou
por sobrevivência
então eu quero deixar aqui um convite
para uma reflexão que se tornou contínua
pra mim que é sobre como a gente trata
os nossos próprios sonhos e os que estão
em volta da gente tem observado os seus
vieses preconceitos privilégios
nesse tempo de transformação que tem se
dado espaço para entender como você quer
contribuir para um mundo mais justo
o mais inclusivo e buscando formas de
agir nesse caminho
a gente não precisa ser sócio parceiro
amigo de quem a gente não quiser mas se
a gente trabalhar para deixar de ser um
criador de nó a gente já vai está
contribuindo muito para a nossa própria
felicidade e realização porque essa
mesma voz que julga e limita o outro
está julgando e limitando você pra
finalizar
eu quero deixar um convite aqui pra todo
mundo e eu quero que você responda
vamos juntos
[Música]
[Aplausos]